the freaky found none in The Conjuring
movies is pure nightmare fuel but the
actress under the makeup looks entirely
different you've probably seen her in
other movies without realizing it upon
its original release in 2013 The
Conjuring was simply a standalone
supernatural horror movie Lucy based on
a true story and thus entirely to any of
the iconic horror properties of decades
past in the years since however the film
has spawned its own Cinematic Universe
with Myriad spin-off flakes focused on
some of its more iconic villains
including a certain evil nun
who's that
[Music]
in 2016's a Conjuring 2 the
investigators from the first film played
by Patrick Wilson and Vera Farmiga
returned to investigate a suspected
possession in a borough of London during
their investigation they find out that
the evil spirit responsible for the
possession is not acting alone but
working at the behest of a demonic nun
known as valek despite the nun's
importance to the story her total
on-screen presence and her original
appearance is pretty minimal due to her
role as a shadowy figure behind the film
Supernatural events that changed when
the prequel movie The Nun was released
in 2018 giving an origin story of souls
for valix murderous non-incarnation with
how much of a staple valak has become in
the horror movie scene fans of the cards
that may be curious about the actor who
plays her and what she looks like in
real life behind all the makeup is none
other than Bonnie Aaron's an actor who
is no stranger to playing inhuman
characters due to how monstrous some of
the roles across the filmography of bean
there's a solid chance you've seen
Bonnie Aaron's outside of her role as a
nun without even recognizing her the
list of projects featuring Aaron's as a
super Supernatural creature of some sort
is sizeable however arguably her most
notable credits on this front is Harvard
and David Lynch's Mulholland Drive in
Mulholland Drive Aaron's portrays a
character accredited simply as the bum
the character is arguably insignificant
to the film's story but nevertheless
acts as a focal point of one of the
film's most iconic scenes in a 2014
interview with vulture before The
Conjuring 2 Aaron's described the role
as her absolute favorite from her career
she also noted that she rarely gets
recognized for the role saying I'm very
chameleon-like put a little makeup on me
I look completely different I gotta tell
you I don't scare easily so no no that's
scary that's scary all that said Aaron's
filmography likewise includes a number
of holy human roles in movies with no
such paranormal elements those include
the princess diaries and Shallow Hal
among others Bonnie Aaron's none may be
an icon of mainstream horror Cinema
these days but things weren't always so
Rosy for the actor when it comes to the
screen in an interview at The Hollywood
Reporter Aarons recalled that she had
trouble booking roles early on in her
career and comments from casting
directors didn't help her motivation she
said everybody has a different way of
getting somewhere and that's not the
same formula for everyone I can say I've
had a difficult time I've literally been
told oh no one is interested in seeing
you no one wants to see somebody that
looks like you on TV nonetheless Aaron's
persisted in pursuing her dream until
she caught the eye of a certain esteemed
horror director who happened to be
developing The Conjuring 2. Aaron said
if you really want to do something you
keep doing it it didn't make me stop
umpteen years later hey James one thinks
I'm beautiful enough snagging the role
of the nun proved to be a life-changing
win for Aaron but she also believes it
to be a success story for women in
Monster movie roles telling we got this
covered I am so thrilled to show the
industry that a woman can do this type
of role that has been dominated by men
throughout history and I definitely hope
it opens more doors
foreign